-Bill, I want to ask.
You have three lovely daughters.
Are they fans of your work?
Have they engaged with anything
you've done yet?
-Well, they know me from,
like, a lot of animated movies
like "Inside Out" and "Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs."
I did show them a couple of --
they wanted to, you know --
I had the thing where, you know,
my oldest came in -- she's 11 --
and said, "Hey, kids at school
said you were on a show
called 'Saturday Night Live,'"
and I go, "Yeah."
So I showed her
and her sister Harper the --
I was like,
"What do I show them?"
And I ended up showing them
the puppet sketch,
where I was the puppet --
-Fantastic.
-And they thought
that was funny.
And then I showed them
the one where I, again,
another John Solomon,
Rob Klein sketch
where I was kind of
this effeminate firefighter.
-[ Laughs ] It's one of
my favorites, with Adam Levine.
-Adam Levine, yeah, and it was
called "The Firehouse Incident."
And they were
really confused by that.
And then I watched --
and then I showed them Stefon,
and my oldest,
after the third one went,
"Do you laugh in all of these?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, yeah, I do.
And she goes -- I go,
"But my friend John Mulaney,
he was writing stuff
I hadn't seen."
And she was like, "Alright."
[ Laughter ]
-I think about the firefighter
sketch more than maybe anybody
because your character finds out
that they canceled
a television show.
"Don't Tell the --" What was it?
"Don't Tell --"
-Uh...
-"Don't Tell the Bee
in Apartment --"
-23.
-Yeah.
-Bobby Moynihan walks in
and goes, "Did you hear
they canceled
'The Bee in Apartment 23'?"
And I go, "What?!"
-You go,
"They canceled the bee?!"
-"Canceled the bee?!"
And then I think I say, "Open
that window because I want to
throw a dog out the window,"
and everybody goes, "No!"
[ Laughter ]
-And your kids thought
that was weird?
Hey --
-They weren't into it.
And I blew my voice out
doing it, I remember.
-We do talk about Second Chance
Theater a lot of this show.
And I believe "Song for Daddy,"
was that also Klein and Solomon?
-[ Laughs ]
We're just talking about John
Solomon and Rob Klein sketches,
which were amazing, but, yeah,
"Song for Daddy"
was Justin Bieber.
And that sketch
only went to dress,
and everything that could
possibly go wrong
in a sketch went wrong
during that sketch.
Immediately I think the set
almost fell on Justin Bieber.
-Right.
-And then I tried to make it,
like, a part of the sketch
or something.
And then I remember
none of the props
I was supposed to have
were there.
And it went --
it just went terrible.
And then at the end, I remember
Kenan Thompson came in
as Steve Harvey, and he went,
"I don't know. I like it."
And it was almost like he was
talking about the sketch.
[ Laughs ]
But I can remember --
My favorite memory of that
was going upstairs after it
happened and going up to
the writers room on nine,
still in my costume,
and walking into the
writers room on the ninth floor
and James Anderson
just on the floor, laughing,
and he tackled me
and started laughing
because it was, like, this --
Everybody was just like,
"That was..."
-Yeah.
-That was one of the classic,
like, everything
that could go wrong --
I think it's online someplace,
but it just ate it.
-It was also -- It was,
like, height of Bieber fever.
And I think in those days,
probably now too,
when you have dress rehearsals,
sometimes that's when I feel
like NBC executives, like,
pull tickets for their kids.
And so it was a way younger
crowd, and they were just there
because they loved him,
and the sketch started,
and immediately the set almost
fell on him and people gasped.
-I'm an old, grizzled cowboy
singing a song about his daddy,
and I remember getting up there
and seeing the crowd,
and Fred Armisen
was playing the drummer.
And Fred was like, "There's a
lot of, like, young kids here."
[ Laughter ]
And I was just like,
"Oh, we're screwed.
This isn't going to play."
And just seeing John Solomon
just in the audience,
pleasantly looking at me, going
like -- just knowing like --
I was in front of
a firing squad, you know.
-It was -- We'll do it here
one day and we'll just have
a grizzled audience
full of cowboys for you.
Just like old --
Because that's who it was for.
-That's who it was for. Yeah.
-Buddy, thank you so much
for being here.
It is always such a joy
and a pleasure to see your face.
-You too, pal.
-I'll see you soon.